and breaking news today the chinese
government threatened retaliation on
wednesday
after the u.s ordered the chinese to
close the consulate
in houston texas over concerns it was
being used for espionage
this after the doj announced that it has
charged two chinese hackers with trying
to steal
united states coronavirus research here
with reaction
louisiana senator john kennedy you've
been very outspoken on this
uh look the fact that after
all of these years that we had people
30 and 40 years ago hacking into
government agencies and we don't fix
this
annoys the living daylights out of me at
what point is that our problem and our
fault
the communist party of china
has become a world comorbidity
and america allowed it for
well over 20 years too many of our
leaders
sean got up every day and they just took
the bullet train to chumptown
we didn't stand up to china now we are
and we ask we ask other countries to
join with us
i don't want a cold war with china china
says
the communist party in china says it
wants to wants respect
you have to earn respect respect is not
a participation
trophy they have to show that they're
willing
to be vested stakeholders in a stable
world order
in in in vernacular that means they have
to agree to stop cheating
innocent people died because of all of
their lies
they now want to steal our information
they've
intellectual property theft has been a
huge problem
trade and balance a huge problem
we now must remove all the manufacturing
especially for vital items like agents
for
medicines and pharmaceuticals how do
what do you propose we do
the first thing that i would do is ask
other other members of the western world
to join with us
australia is already there the united
kingdom's already there but i'm thinking
specifically
of our friends in europe the eu
it's time that the the eu uh grew some
oranges and said you know we
we stand for something they're weak
senator
they are weak and and they could be much
stronger
um but but they're so worried about
making money
from and with china that in my judgment
they sacrificed
their values i don't mean to overstate
it there have been a few of the
countries that have pushed back
but they need to push back as a as a
group as an organization particularly
uh um germany
well i agree with everything people in
your state
and every state in this country died
because of what they did
and around the world why wouldn't people
unite on that we have about 20 seconds
it's it's not just the coronavirus it's
everything else too
as bad as a coronavirus is sean yeah
all right senator always appreciate you
being with us thank you sir